what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and today we have some
Sony spider-verse news that is actually
quite good of course that is if they
pull it off correctly but it looks like
The Amazing Spider-Man 3 could be made
I'm not saying this is confirmed but it
looks like there is a chance that the
Amazing Spider-Man 3 is actually
happening and I think Sony has a
legitimate plan here and I think that
this plan actually makes sense it's all
going to be building up to one big event
kind of like Marvel Studios does leading
up to the big Avengers films this is
essentially what Sony might be doing
right now setting up a spider verse to
eventually lead to a huge Spider-Man
movie The Avengers Infinity war and
Avengers end games of Spider-Man and yes
I know what you're thinking we kind of
already got that with Spider-Man no way
home however this could actually be
bigger as crazy as that sounds but again
it depends if Sony he does it right but
it does look like they actually have a
plan and we're going to go over that
plan today so if you love Marvel and you
love Spider-Man and want to stay up to
date on everything be sure to subscribe
and hit that notification Bell so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos so an Insider in our Marvel
Superhero pop culture Community recently
posted to their Twitter a list of Sony
films that they've seen that are going
to be coming to the Sony Universe of
Spider-Man I don't actually know what
they're calling their Universe now it
used to be the spumc the Sony Pictures
Universe of Marvel characters now we
just call the spider-verse whatever it
may be now this list is great it lists
some movies but what it really tells us
is the actual plan that Sony has so
first let's go over this list it's from
film Odyssey MCU that's the Twitter
handle and the list is El muerto Madame
web Craven the hunter Sandman and Rhino
morbius 2 The Amazing Spider-Man spider
getting now that's all they originally
posted with the caption a list I've seen
you figure out the rest however they
eventually did do a follow-up tweet
stating getting a few DMS about this
Venom 3 was not on the list that I copy
and pasted onto this tweet but yes it's
coming the ones that I didn't copy over
that were on a separate message were
Venom 3 the itsv sequels silk series
plus two Untitled projects sorry for the
confusion also if you don't know what
the itsv sequels are itsv is into the
spider-verse now we know about most of
these in fact most of them have already
been announced by Sony El moreto Madam
Webb Craven the hunter Venom 3 a silk
series and of course some sequels for
into the spider-verse we knew about
those however the ones that catch my eye
on here are one first and foremost a
Sandman and Rhino series or movie We're
not too sure about that but that's
interesting to say the least not what I
really would have expected but of course
my eyes really actually go to The
Amazing Spider-Man and spider-geden
these two could be absolutely huge
spider-geden is kind of like the secret
Wars of Spider-Man it's a bunch of
different Spider-Man variants coming
together we're gonna talk more about
this in a bit but I want to talk about
Sony's overall plan first now this list
is seemingly just a bunch of different
projects thrown out there however if you
actually just focus on a few we can
start to see Sony's plan if we
specifically look at these projects
Madame Webb The Amazing Spider-Man
spider get in and Venom 3 we can see it
kind of come together here I should also
mention that it just says The Amazing
Spider-Man and I do believe this would
be the Amazing Spider-Man 3. they
wouldn't just call it the Amazing
Spider-Man we of course already have a
movie called The Amazing Spider-Man so I
assume this is The Amazing Spider-Man 3
and even let's say if they did want to
reboot I don't think they should call it
the Amazing Spider-Man because that
would just be confusing they wouldn't
title it exactly the same as another
movie but talks since Spider-Man no way
home have been going on about how Andrew
Garfield is most likely returning to the
Sony Spider-Man universe because Sony
wants him to return also the fans truly
did love him in no way home and there
was a petition going around to make The
Amazing Spider-Man 3 happen and I'm
assuming Sony knows what's going on so
this is The Amazing Spider-Man 3 in my
mind I don't really have any doubt so
let's take a look at what they're doing
here one is it looks like Andrew
Garfield will return for The Amazing
Spider-Man 3. we've had a ton of reports
from very credible insiders that state
that he is going to be coming doing The
Amazing Spider-Man 3 Sony wants it he
wants it so it should happen it's not
guaranteed but it should happen now
Andrew Garfield returning sets up Venom
3. we know that Tom Hardy wants Venom 3
to be a Venom vs Spider-Man movie he's
already actually teased Spider-Man Bean
in the third film plus we did get the
post credit of Venom looking at Tom
Holland Spider-Man then he ended up in
the MCU but then of course in no way
home that post-credits scene sent him
back to the Sony spider-verse just
basically giving us a big middle finger
but what did actually did was set up the
fact that now Venom knows who Spider-Man
is and will most likely seek out the
Spider-Man in his Universe which will
most likely be Andrew Garfield and that
will be Venom 3 but then you have Madam
Webb now in the comics Madam Webb is
essentially a cosmic being with the
power to travel through the Multiverse
and this is actually quite a big movie
for the Sony Universe again if they do
it right Sony is essentially setting up
their own Multiverse which we kind of
already did but in the MCU however they
did throw venom into the MCU and then
brought him back they took vulture from
the MCU and brought vulture into the
Sony spider-verse and Andrew Garfield's
and Toby Maguire Spider-Man were from
the Sony Universe maybe not the main one
that our Venom is in but they're from
some type of Sony universe so a
Multiverse does exist within the
Spider-Man universe and now we have
Madame Webb coming into play a
Multiverse film and at first I was
wondering what exactly are they going to
do with Madame web what exactly are they
going to do with the spider-verse but
now that I see this name on this list
spider-geden it does make sense if this
is the true direction that Sony is going
to go basically Sony is building up
their Spider-Man universe to essentially
have a huge event bigger than Spider-Man
no way home where we see multiple
Spider-Man on screen and I know what
most people say well can it get bigger
than Spider-Man no way home and of
course it can there are so many
different variations of Spider-Man out
there that have not been on screen with
our main Spider-Man yet we have Miles
Morales we have spider Gwyn we have
Spider Woman we have Spider-Man 2099 Ben
Reilly spider Noir there's just a ton
but spider getting is where we could
actually see all of these Spider-Man
come together on screen in the spider
get in storyline there's basically every
single Spider-Man in that story they
even took the Spider-man from the video
game and brought him into that Marvel
Universe which is pretty insane but also
it extremely cool so basically nothing
is off limits if Sony decides to do this
movie however there is one big thing
that I think Sony needs to do to make
this work because I keep talking about
if they do it right because this movie
could be amazing but it could also be a
big letdown if they don't do it right
and the one thing I think they need to
do is listen to Kevin feige the
president of Marvel Studios he's done a
great job with the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and he did a great job of
course with John Watts with Spider-Man
no way home he also of course has done
Infinity war and end game and Secret
Wars coming up and I think spider gedden
could in some type of way tie into
Secret Wars whether it's Spider-Man
going oh yes I know that there are a ton
of different Spider-Man variants out
there because of Secret Wars or in
secret Wars Spider-Man goes oh yeah I
have some friends that could help and he
brings in a bunch of Spider-Man variants
from other universes because of what
happened in spider getting but I do
think Secret Wars will most likely come
up first overall I do think this would
be an amazing plan by Sony to have their
Universe lead up to a spider get in but
they need to do it right and Kevin feige
right now is said to be Consulting with
them on every Spider-Man project that
they're doing which is awesome nobody
knows Marvel like Kevin feige so if they
build it up the right way which again
Kevin feige is helping them do and they
listen to Kevin feige take his advice
and actually let him handle some things
as well this could be the biggest
Spider-Man movie of all time which
sounds weird because not too long ago we
were talking about Spider-Man no way
home being that but again if they do
this right it could be huge but let me
know your thoughts about this in the
comments down below what do you think
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to stay up to date on the
latest news for live updates you can
follow me on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
okay